perhaps no surprise that the Israelis
will assume that this attack in Tel Aviv
is potentially linked to their operation
in Janine
yeah that's exactly what they'll think
the security forces in Israel itself
have been on a lower definitely law
corporation in the early hours of
yesterday morning not just for Terror
attacks taking place within Israel
itself but also the potential for
looking Fire coming from the garden
strip or perhaps the northern border
from Lebanon from uh and that none of
those two things have happened uh yet a
message has been sentences from our
plans
are saying drinks getting involved but
what we have Frank is newswise in Tel
Aviv is a terror attack which I'm pretty
serious the car running incident
possibly stabbing incident as well local
media here reporting seven people
wounded two of those seriously uh and so
we'll have to we can see more coming out
from that in terms of the what's
happening where I am in Gene and it's
the second day of the Israeli military
operations it was quite quiet overnight
I think the Israelis have been a little
surprised at times of how Little
Resistance they've been getting from
some of the Palestinian militants inside
Janine particular Jeep company in Janine
but the operation continues I'm just
watching now a column of Israeli armored
vehicles
mining past us I can hear the constant
harm and buzzing of drones overheads as
we know they're using drones to start
the operation around the past one in the
morning yesterday morning and take out
what they described as a joint Operation
Center right in the center machine and I
think it's at the middle by surprise I
can see a massive Dark Bloom of smoke as
well it comes in the center city to get
in here you've got to drive weave your
way through barricades have been put in
the road and lots of tires burning smoke
people on the street saying that they
will Define me push away any kind of
Israeli operation
um
moments the death toll is tended more
than 100 wounded I wouldn't surprise if
that ride didn't potentially Rising
quite considerably as to how long this
will go on for
the Israelis I mean it can be slightly
questions on the one hand senior figures
are saying that they've achieved almost
all of their objectives and they might
wrap it up sooner than they thought on
the other hand some are saying it might
hit one for another couple of days so I
think the Australians would do what they
want to do
um they do have international pressure
on them safely from humanitarian
organizations in the United Nations but
I think on this case a little bit unlike
when you have flare-ups in Gaza I think
they will continue operating in Janine
for as long as they feel they need to do
so in order to
um either eliminate or arrest
people who they regard as Palestinian
terrorists to seize weapons and
ammunitions and to gather as much
intelligence as possible